is it me or does Joseph gordon-levitt
sound like Jack Black in that one scene
of school of rock when he answers the
phone he's like this is mr. Smee bleep I
don't know it's what I thought of yeah
movie about Edward Snowden I thought of
Jack Black that's whatever Snowden so
Snowden is directed by Oliver Stone
Oliver Stone at this point I don't
really hold my breath for anymore it was
a time some time ago people were like
holy [ __ ] is an Oliver Stone movie this
is an event now they're like yeah we'll
say so Snowden is about Edward Snowden
he's the guy in 2013 turned over those
documents to the media showing that the
US government was actually tapping and
monitoring their own citizens to a very
large an insane degree I mean you know
that stuff like that's going to happen
but maybe there's probable cause maybe
there's a good reason this was a lot of
folks Snowden was like they have to be
held accountable for that [ __ ] so I need
to let people know this is happening no
this is not the WikiLeaks guy it was
another movie starring Benedict
Cumberbatch it came out a couple years
ago this was a new thing so what I liked
about this movie is the questions it
actually forces you to ask that's the
point of a movie like this I mean
clearly this Snowden guy he loves
America he loves his country he wants to
serve it well but at that point the
movie forces you to ask what is loyalty
to your country's loyalty to the
government or loyalty to its citizens
the way I see it loyalty to your
country's loyalty to its citizens that
make up the country the government
should serve the citizens thus serve the
country kind of like that quote from V
for Vendetta that I really like where he
says people should not be afraid of
their governments governments should be
afraid of their people I just I like
that quote a lot because it just shows
that a government should have
accountability to its people at a point
this dude was like there is no
accountability here people don't even
know this is happening they should
probably be informed of that so he did
what he did you kind of see this a lot
of times bad things or shady things
start out with good intentions I mean
even if you think what Snowden did was
bad he did it for good intentions he did
it so the government could have
accountability to its citizens but at a
point I'm very sure there was a good
reason for the US government to be like
hey we need to enact this and that so we
can just buy on these people because
they should probably be spied on because
they're tweeting bomb Obama White House
murder and things are pretty that we
should probably follow that person and
then they were like militias follow that
person all right well let's just tap
that guy's internet well let's just tap
that guy's webcam let's tap his foe you
had [ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it it just got
out of control and now it's kind of like
the US government Opera
it's like Alonzo Harris from training
day where he's like we're the polies we
can do another [ __ ] we want there's no
accountability there so anyhow this
movie forces you to be like alright what
is loyalty to your countries to the
people or the government I also like how
it showed how a job like what Snowden
had we're just bombarded with classified
information you can't tell your spouse
that really compromises your
relationships it makes you paranoid it
kind of wrecks you as a person I mean
screw that noise I'd never want a job
like that I'll take being the [ __ ]
online who talks about movies thank you
and I got to say shailene woodley in
this movie not only is she looked better
than a sheet she's super hot in his
movie but beyond that she was also the
best I've ever seen her act she stepped
beyond the realm of the divergent series
thank God and now she's like hey why
don't we kind of make me legit because
that [ __ ] ain't gonna last forever isn't
the last chapter coming too straight to
blu-ray or something like that's
fantastic so I'm glad she actually got a
couple moments to shine in this one but
I gotta say the pacing in this movie was
so slow I mean it's such an interesting
thing that happened this dude who worked
for the NSA was like a man take these
files release him to the press and then
now he's just out there was a huge guy's
been charged with espionage treason a
hundred other things is not allowed back
into the country because God knows bad
shits gonna happen to them the bummer is
that really interesting movie happened
to such a boring guy so really you're
just watching a life happen you're like
alright yeah he's gonna blow the whistle
one day right okay okay it's kind of
like not as bad I mean I need to I need
to illustrate this is not as bad but
it's kind of like that Michael Bay Pearl
Harbor movie how it's called Pearl
Harbor and you're waiting for that to
drop but in the meantime you just kind
of gotta go through the motions to get
to the last half hour but a lot better
than that but you get what I'm saying
it's interesting enough seeing this guy
climbed the ladder of the NSA but it's
only so interesting this movie clocks in
at about two hours 20 minutes that extra
20 minutes past the two hours could have
been cut out somewhere you could have
just Frankensteined a bit and then
crunched it up and there you go guys in
the end the concept of the story of
Snowden is interesting and it's a tale
that should be told
however this two-hour 20 minute movie
that told it didn't always move faster
than his snail's pace and sometimes
you're like all right let's get it going
and a lot of biopics run into this and I
would expect it in some cases but a case
like
this I would feel like this movie would
have me at the edge of my seat the
entire time in the end I saw 10-minute
interview with Snowden on John Oliver's
last week tonight and I found that more
interesting than the entirety of this
movie I'm going to push it on the
premise of importance the movie asks
important questions you reflect on
important things and me personally
Jeremy Jones I found the movie
interesting enough to say I will say
Snowden is a good time no alcohol
required gonna say at matinee price
something about those movies about those
whistleblowers manases you could just
read about it online alright guys so
Snowden have you seen it what did you
think about it or what do you actually
think about what the dude the real dude
actually did are you farty you like yeah
transparency among government people
should happen glad he did that or you
like not [ __ ] that [ __ ] treason I want
to know what you think about it so
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]